hello david hello kim
so today what we're doing is taking a
look at this speech
by one of my favorite presidents
franklin delano roosevelt which he gave
at his inauguration in 1933.
and i think what's really important
about looking at a speech like this is
not only that we can learn to analyze
this as a primary source which will be
helpful for
thinking about it historically but also
because i think it's really useful to be
able to look at a presidential speech or
a speech given by any politician and
understand what kind of claims they're
making and how they're making them
so
kim before we go any further what what
even is a primary source what's the
difference between a primary and a
secondary source great question so a
primary source
is a document
that
takes a look at an event
from the perspective of someone who was
there
so a primary source could be lots of
things
it could be
a photograph
taken by someone who was perhaps
attending a political rally
it could be a diary of maybe someone who
was active in the women's rights
movement in the 19th century
certainly any
speech
or even
would say like a an oral history
conversation and and i've mentioned a
lot of significant things here but it
also doesn't even have to be something
that is connected with a significant
person or a famous event it could be
a shopping list right
if you are studying the consumption
habits of someone who lives in the 1950s
what they bought at the grocery store
would tell you a lot about what they ate
what they could spend
so a primary source is kind of the real
meat of research material that shows you
what people at the time were thinking
okay so a primary source is an artifact
left behind by someone who was there
exactly what is a secondary source so a
secondary source
is an interpretation
so
say i'm a historian which
i happen to be oh my goodness
what a coincidence
so i have done the work of digging up a
bunch of primary sources and then you
look at all of them and see what they
have in common for example so maybe i'm
writing about abraham lincoln and i get
a lot of photographs of lincoln i get a
lot of
writings by lincoln and his
contemporaries and i go through all of
them and
i come up with my interpretation of what
was going on in lincoln's life
so i write a book on lincoln by kim
um until now
and um
that's my interpretation okay right so
the things that i'm interested in
say lincoln's religion or lack thereof
might not be the same things that
another historian would be interested
say they're interested in lincoln's
foreign policy so my interpretation is
just one way of looking at those primary
sources where another historian might
have a completely different
interpretation
what's also important about secondary
sources is that i wasn't there right i
never talked to lincoln he you know died
more than 100 years before i was born
which means that you can only trust me
so much
you can instead maybe get a much clearer
picture of what lincoln was really
thinking by reading his own words
so trust secondary sources about as far
as you can throw them
well maybe trust all sources about as
far as you can throw them right because
everyone at every time has their own
perspective and so
the ideas of someone who lived in the
19th century are going to be different
than the ideas of someone who lives now
and you only know as much as you can
know right you're only as informed as
the information that you have so you
really have to take everything with a
grain of salt and compare it with other
sources from its time period and other
sources later on to get a sense of
what's important so you're saying that
you might have a different perspective
on lincoln than another lincoln scholar
but that lincoln's writings themselves
also contain lincoln's own biases from
his lifetime right okay so what are we
doing with roosevelt's inaugural address
here all right so
let's take a look at this inaugural
address as though we're historians right
we're going to sit down
and really get into the
the feeling of the great depression
all right we're gonna get depressed all
right i'm ready so we've determined that
because he was there and because this is
a speech delivered by him that this
speech of franklin delano roosevelt is a
primary source right and it's a great
way to look at the great depression
right if we want to know what people are
thinking about it's very important to
see what the president of the united
states has to say when he's been elected
so david i know that you've been dying
to read this and your terrific
impression of roosevelt so i'm going to
turn it over to you to get a sense of
what roosevelt has to say okay i'm going
to scoot back from the mic
i am certain that my fellow americans
expect that on my induction into the
presidency i will address them with a
candor and a decision which the present
situation of our people impel this is
preeminently the time to speak the truth
the whole truth frankly and boldly nor
need we shrink from honestly facing
conditions in our country today
this great nation will endure as it has
endured we'll revive and will prosper
so first of all let me assert my firm
belief that the only thing we have to
fear is fear itself nameless unreasoning
unjustified terror which paralyzes
needed efforts to convert retreat into
advance that was beautiful
thank you so much you're welcome all
right so
how do we analyze this as a primary
source and as a speech i think the first
thing we want to do step one if you will
is just identify what's going on and
thankfully that's pretty easy for us
right now right this is a speech given
by the president of the united states in
the moment that he becomes president
right so we know when it was
in
march 4th 1933
we know who
gave this speech
uh franklin delano roosevelt just about
to be inducted as president
we know why he gave it right very
important for
presidents when they take office to make
an inaugural address so we've got some
basics here we can even infer from the
inaugural address where this was given
right in washington dc
all right so in our identification we've
got that it's a speech it's in dc it
happened in 1933
by fdr so that's our identification
stage
so to get it a little deeper level for
this let's let's move on to a second
step which would be kind of giving some
context
so it's 1933 what's going on
um let's see so
um the great depression has been going
on for four years
um prohibition has not ended yet right
right repeal has not come so
liquor is still illegal in the united
states for um
for sale and transport there's massive
unemployment the dust bowl is still
raging america is not in the greatest
place no it it's a depression and it's a
depression in all sorts of ways right uh
people are emotionally depressed and
there's an economic depression all right
so we've got the general gist now that
this is a speech from 1933
confronting the great depression so
let's get into a little bit more of the
specifics what is he actually talking
about in this speech
well if we look at this speech you can
kind of see
that he's acknowledging that things are
bad right right
it's time to speak the truth
so he keeps talking about how you know
it's time to speak the truth we'll
address the american people with candor
it is time to speak the truth the whole
truth frankly and boldly
uh we will not shrink from honestly
facing conditions in the country today
um so roosevelt is really priming
everyone to say like okay
you have not been told the truth from
your head of government for the longest
time and now it's time to deal frankly
with just how bad things have gotten and
what's interesting is that he says
things are not you know great
but
uh
in every in every dark hour of our
national life a leadership of frankness
and vigor has met with that
understanding and support of the people
themselves which is essential to victory
and he's saying that there's no need to
be
afraid of anything except just malaise
he's saying that americans need to meet
the problem of the depression with like
an upwelling of national will
right and i think you know it's nice
that he's saying look i'm gonna tell it
like it is things are bad i recognize
that things are bad and that's pretty
important because up until this point
herbert hoover hadn't really done much
to recognize that things were bad you
know he saw that people were suffering
and yet he said this is not necessarily
the responsibility of government to deal
with this crisis so roosevelt actually
calls it a dark hour of our national
life right like this is uh acknowledging
that things are not great is a big part
of this speech but he's also saying that
it's possible for us to bounce back if
we are honest about the problems and we
address it with vigor and that is kind
of the new deal right is addressing the
problems honestly and with national
exuberance
yeah and i think this is such a
fascinating speech because
for one thing this phrase has kind of
come into our our national lexicon right
there's nothing to fear but fear itself
which is kind of strange it's one of
those things like have your cake and eat
it too that you're like
wait how is that possible so what does
he mean by the only thing we have to
fear is fear itself i think he's saying
that this is no time to panic and that
the only thing that we should be afraid
of is unreasoning terror we shouldn't be
running around like chickens with our
heads cut off
right like this is the time to stand
firm against nameless terror and focus
on making the problems that we are
facing into small like accessible
combatable chunks i think another thing
that's important about what he's saying
there is that
the great depression is caused by
something
that is very new in american culture
which is the stock market and the stock
market doesn't play by the rules of
straight supply and demand instead they
play on confidence
and so
the reason that the stock market crash
of 1929 happens is because people stop
having confidence that stocks are worth
as much as the stock market says they
are so everyone pulls out there's a
panic and global banking pretty much
collapses and that's a really hard thing
to deal with right i mean it's not like
you're
taking your money out of the bank or me
taking my money out of the bank at any
one time could cause an international
depression right but when there is a
large group of people who all get
panicked at the same time and take their
money out of the banks the banks fail
right and so i think what roosevelt is
saying is that we cannot allow a
sweeping wave of panic to come over the
nation again exactly so that's the
context for this speech is things are
bad the reason things are bad is because
of this wave of nameless unreasoning
unjustified terror and
america i need your support to make sure
that we don't let that happen again so
that we can turn this retreat into an
advance in our next video we'll go more
into how we can analyze this source and
use it to construct an argument of our
own